hey it's real 92.3 baby it's the real
after-party with myself bootleg keV DJ
damage I got a special guest in the bill
here yeah I'm gonna screws name up sir
Bailey nice I think it's a baby so there
we go why you let me say it I can also
[ __ ] it up me leave I was trying to have
you say the name no you wanted me to
jump in are we still working on this
well welcome to a bootleg captain West
Coast just like you man yeah it's a
special moment right now I've lived on
the work Arizona's Wescoe well my la
well so look man this song is heating up
I mean 12 million views on YouTube is
like a four so YouTube checks got to be
kind of nice right now I'm gonna receive
no YouTube
oh yeah no I just got in the bank just
kind of it's on worldstar channel
yeah I saw a world star chariot in the
check did you see my hit Emilien on my
channel sudo okay I grant you on that
man we shake that yo how old are you I'm
20 you're 20 years old yeah yeah I was
20 years old I was getting no vagina
hahaha you're out here I'm sure you're
on you're smashing you're on you're
literally pulling this like to stick out
like it's your person right believe
right we'll be in 20 years old and
having a semi hit record it's obviously
an internet sensation the song that most
of how's it feel man
and the feel great man a lot of people
saying that man the crowd be energetic
yeah form and stuff like that I see a
lot of celebrities making videos too so
man they feel great you mean you got a
drink verse on there speak things
happening yeah I don't know yet well no
I mean he did it he didn't he didn't do
that no it didn't happen uh I'm not sure
okay what is up with that how are you
not for sure yeah I thought I thought
that was a man okay comb and comb you
dig
ah I know with hopped on it yeah yeah
we're either gonna pull away that's it
yeah yeah that cover was fine do you
like that one artists do covers on your
tracks yeah yeah most definitely
that's showing love Oh t-pain did one
Fetty WAP please yeah all them shows any
what do one yeah yes get one that's a
big deal um how old were you in
t-pain is poppin I had to be like like
six yeah like really ate some high empty
pages yeah long ago
20 bro that you understand t-pain was
poppin like 2004 mmm I was like Tina
from Ian something like no no no so when
t-paint hopped on the Sun did your
parents have to tell you who he was
hey George I'm not oh yeah ever know
Suzanne you're cold man
although you originally from Chicago
right yeah yeah yeah I was raised in
Atlanta raised in Atlanta from Chicago
subculture yo the videos like the most
amount of guns I've ever seen in a video
a lot of everything that's the Chicago
on them right there it's like it's like
it's almost like I thought I was on
ready to keep video yeah
but it obviously was your video yeah for
sure yeah we had a lot of states in
there yeah literally
well like were the cops at we are afraid
the cops are gonna pull up like
literally okay baby for look what we
just hear tomorrow wait how did you wait
how does that work what's the what's the
message brokers we might unite this
where we're [ __ ] we can pull out guns
I don't know we just got that hand put
them in jackets coats oh hell we can
find yo if I'm not mistaken like your
parents are heavily involved in your
careers different your dad is your
monitor ops my manager you pops Uranus
yeah yeah that's my pops ha snaps after
that that's all right right there right
yeah yeah they're like t-pain kinda you
mean like we're bigger yes a8 but but
that's I wanted to ask you like
obviously I read that your parents quit
their jobs like to help with your career
right is that true yeah yeah yeah yeah I
think pops the acquittees up yeah it's
right here why don't we have to yeah
yeah yeah yeah you J food is up mom do
so have no job I want to know is like
obviously you're his dad that the video
got crazy amounts of guns in it
did you like know what to do with all
these sticks oh it makes things chaotic
so you're leaning on the Second
Amendment for this would believe a shot
Neville from but not in Republican [ __ ]
John the pumps no one is right yeah we
need okay so I want to talk about some
projects he had in the past maybe cuz
they got some interesting mail yeah the
best time ever
he pronounces this sand as sandy Sanders
Sanders yeah
can you tell cap what that means please
you gonna let it sucka [ __ ] Deakins oh
I told you doing luck holy [ __ ] I'm
gonna soar as I do I love that [ __ ] I
have heard oh it's a movement and rays
are conceding GD it's good you have a
song that's that's that yeah yeah
Sanders this day in fresh air the strip
club yeah most definitely
oh my god just saw one called blocks and
thoughts and I thought that [ __ ] was the
most ignorant amazing show so he's gonna
love it oh my god yo we drop in the
remasters chicken I leave it you know
what what's done with the inspiration
there you just did you dedicate that to
some girl you're trying to get to you
know top you all forge an eye on the
world you want the world of yeah this
fellatio periodization smart man he
knows the scientifical he knew he was on
radio today
yeah you said yes amen believe it I
believe it speechless my G oh it's the
best title Pirie so uh you say you were
raised in Atlanta who are like your
influences because you're 20 years old
so obviously like I said t-pain was
poppin when you were like a little baby
so who was like you know you're hanging
t-pain from alumni saying rich kids
coming up right cash out the future Quan
I seen all I know Lee yeah yeah yeah
I'll wait it was poppin in the city so
I'll let it spam well do you feel like
um now that you have everything you got
a record deal um they're young men you
know it's a family operation does it
feel like a lot of responsibilities on
your back like you got a lot of people
depending on you manda like everyone's
listen are you worried about like uh you
know a lot of a lot of dudes get in the
game and they um you know they get
caught slippin a to get caught doing
dumb [ __ ] you know the fan whether it's
sliding the wrong broad the ends yeah or
just you know smoking weed or trying to
pass your TSA with weed in your soup
caldo just some dumb [ __ ] but like you
feel like I mean you feel like I feel
like you got your head on your shoulders
just based on you know a you know our
short time and
I go and go get caught Norman like that
you are you a good kid is what I'm
saying because you watch the videos a
lot of guns in there you know you're on
a gum definitely a great guy you're a
great guy great yeah I want to know
about high school man cuz you know you
fresh out you fresh out of high school
you know did you go back and you know
stump real quick cuz I know I would have
not now you hit the high school yet is
it just like a not yet or you're not
trying to do one go back and talk to
okay did you graduate from high school
yeah okay so the the rose to anybody in
high school who you want to have sex
with that you didn't have sex with while
you're in high school but you smashed
after you start to get like getting
popping so that's what I would do
I'm like you know here's the list of
[ __ ] that won't give me no play in
high school now that I've got 12 million
views on YouTube I'm gonna go try to
land is all of them it's a couple of
them hitting me up man did you entertain
them no no not [ __ ] not yet but I just
started I just had this above other
chick though who say like it is it's a
great you got a girlfriend
honestly yeah that's what it is it makes
it nice so you're you're like you meet
her on bumble or 10:09 me don't did you
meet her the old-fashioned way like my
Facebook MySpace
who are the girls yeah now I'm in hell
person okay our Instagram I quite okay
this is totally random but were you old
enough like did you ever have a myspace
like were you alive yeah I had a minor
no I just run ahead on my face so what's
next man the singles crazy what do you
got coming down the pipeline now that
you got a deal - oh we got yeah yeah so
shows but we got that sounders remaster
coming soon right on this month we got a
free bonus tracks on there and we
shooting some videos on the new one way
or purple wait over here la we almost
dislocated man who you're trying to work
with um what is wrong right obviously
the Drake versus coming in oh yeah oh no
no yes later figure can you confirm that
the Drake versus happening like right
now not rankle fire now uh but uh have
you ever talked to Drake yeah yeah I
talked to you talk to him send me if
he's gonna get on the song drink is like
really good at hopping on waves and I
feel he's gonna hop all over your wave
but it could be good
it's gonna be like what happened amigos
in Versace yeah yeah for show faster the
hell they do it was a super big look at
I love Makonnen yeah now I don't know
what he's doing where is he he was just
you know Drake gets on a song and it
goes the next level I hope that happens
for him you know
anyway look follow you on Instagram
people your your name is hexagonal it
out s ahbab is our baby and where's the
name come from
oh well you know my name Sahin and okay
people call me selfish or my auntie nine
right T baby she just gave me the baby
part of that family of therapy
100% man and I've been at a point in
time I know you guys are moving around
right now where your parents have had to
like tell you not to do something like
where your dad had to be like okay I'm
not your manager I'm your dad only two
girls at the same time son hahaha yeah
yeah we have like some females we come
to the house and stuff like that didn't
he didn't pop some oh now your mom and
dad they're still together
oh yeah yeah hey welcome here good man
your parents are lit man believe it
hahaha gonna get a verse put him on a
camera again one more time this is who
you got an email for that guest boy yeah
but his Instagram for all the guest
verse situations and inquiries we're
looking forward to hearing more music
with Naima Schulman and he was just
overseas - yeah I was in the London
London
yeah always wait I was well know you
believe yo young Doug um I'm a fan of
his music he seems like a real like
weird dude I was in person I never met
him oh yeah all good yeah that our
person well did you meet his like
Beyonce chick yeah yeah she was around
yeah she was around she seems like she
wears the pants literally because it
wears yeah yeah they ended up funny
relationship
it's really yeah I was watching an
interview on Vice the end they were
trying to interview young thug uh-huh
his girl was talking for is the hole you
need that sometimes man imbalance all
right man well look you could go get the
the songs definitely on iTunes yeah most
listen
you got to make some money off a little
bit of steep the video watch it on his
channel
world searching yeah support get
shouting world started be doing that I
mean they're smart yeah look yeah we'll
put you on our channels we got like 2
million subscribers their most different
heat lamp it you can you to to start
their community life here a thousand
every Amelie
anything else you want to say to the
people man man people are like keep
trying with me man and uh it's more I
have to pull up with a stick man just
keep listening man Sanders remaster
coming very soon man lot of melodic
Tunes man did you vote vote fool I'm
just actually because no soul no you
didn't vote I don't know ask he's a he's
a big Second Amendment guy so if I was
running for Trump
you know what vocal none of them guys
none edible so I baby I only introduced
is on a man stop begging mister pull up
with his stick Milotic man go get that
now
iTunes whatever believe it eggs for
ninety two three